[Musique]
gagne le premier titre mondial de super
sprint à Hambourg en Allemagne
l'ancienne pensionnaire du club de
triathlon de Poissy a remporté cette
nouvelle compétition composée de 300
mètres de natation 7,5 km de vélo et
1,75 km de course à pied et glinoise
terminé avec un temps de 21 minutes et
35 secondes la sportive devance la
Britannique baisse Potter de 10 secondes
estime son troisième succès sur le
circuit wtcs après Hambourg en 2018
Elite en 2022 en football FC Versailles
a disputé deux rencontres amicales au
stade biellement à Lisieux les yvelo en
fait match nul 0 à 0 contre quevillot en
métropole une équipe de Ligue 2 et ils
ont signé une victoire face au Red Star
1-0 avec une réalisation de Gerry
Bangoura de kenshit sur ces deux
premiers matchs amicaux de la saison les
joueurs de la cité royale joueront leur
premier rencontre du championnat de
National le 11 août prochain à domicile
contre Annecy ou Sochaux toujours en
football living Champions League s'est
terminé ce week-end cette compétition
qui a réuni 16 équipes du département
délivrer son verdict lors de la finale
Les Mureaux se sont imposés 2-1 face à
Trappes au stade Robert gravo de Trappes
il soulève donc la première coupe de
living Champions League vu le succès
rencontré cette année une nouvelle
édition devrait être programmée à
l'année prochaine enfin en basket le
chez les courtois Hugo Doumbia et le
trappiste Hugo l'Europe avec l'équipe de
France des moins de 20 ans ils se sont
imposés 49 à 79 face au jeunes
israéliens ce dimanche 16 juillet en
Grèce même s'ils ont commencé sur le
banc ils ont joué ils ont aidé la France
à revenir au score Hugo Doumbia vient de
signer au Mans pour trois ans égaux
mi-innandy sera quant à lui un joueur de
l'étoile en jet basket